dan if you could supply filmmakers with
a checklist of do's and don'ts before
they make their movie sort of these you
know film festival do's and Nils before
they make their film that would improve
their chances of getting into a festival
what would they be
so my advice before you even made your
movie is number one to go to a few film
festivals and just find out like oh
that's what people are making these days
or that's what people aren't making
these days and you know and this is in a
short should be Oh short said this long
and I see shorts before features and
that's because they're under 10 minutes
I like it or I go to a short film
festival and that's where longer shorts
are or this genre features are getting
million this year you know because I
think what frequently happens is that
people will sometimes make what they
think is the hot film of what film
festivals want to expect so consequently
you get you know over the years at slam
dance and other festivals you know you
would see this litany of films that were
you know about six best friends all
sitting around taking drugs talking
about how they were going to film
themselves robbing a bank and you're
like if I see one more film like that
I'm gonna shoot myself yeah I'm gonna
shoot them instead of them shooting each
other and you know and that was kind of
the trend for a while but it was like
but that was that was the problems
people were seeing like the Tarantino
movie or the Kevin Smith movie or
whatever and say oh I'm gonna make that
movie well now by the time you've made
that movie it's now three years later
and you wouldn't have been cutting-edge
even one year later you know but you've
got to make something original so I
think originality is the one advice and
whether that's in style form content
narrative you know there's got to be
something original about it or else the
film festival programmers anything get
really bored and and turn it off within
the first 10 minutes and they do that so
and that's the other things your first
10 minutes has to be really good if it's
a narrative feature in your first 1
minute that's why really good if it's a
short because yeah festival programmers
acquisitions executives they will turn
off your film very quickly
but but other way but otherwise my
advice is make the movie you want to
make don't make a movie just to get into
Film Festival's make the thing that
you're passionate about and don't listen
certainly don't listen any Film Festival
program or director after you've started
making the film you know because I've
seen that happen like you know they'll
submit a rough cut and someone will say
yeah that's good and we'll think about
it if you do this and then I start
tinkering it's like no don't listen to
anyone just do your own thing or however
listen to your own team of people
however you you are as a filmmaker but
don't listen to any Film Festival person
tell you what to do because it will be
the wrong advice whatever it is because
at the end of the day filmmakers have to
live with these films they are your
babies and whether they're sitting in
your closet or they're sitting on it or
you've got a shelf full of filled with
Oscars it's your film and 20 years later
you've got to look at that thing and say
oh am i proud of this we're not proud of
it or oh did I compromise to get into
some festival that I didn't get into
anyway you know so you know I think it's
I think people more often than not try
to rush their post-production to get
into a festival it's you know to get
into a certain deadline or they'll rush
their production schedule to get into
thinking that they're gonna get into
Sundance or Toronto or whatever it is
and I think that's always a mistake that
said it can be somewhat helpful to kind
of push things along and post-production
like oh okay you know there is this
festival deadline let's let's get a cut
in by then so that's a that gives us a
deadline you get a cut done but let's
keep working you know that that's not
gonna be a final cut you know so but a
lot of filmmakers sort of fall prey to
that you know methodology uh-oh we've
got Sundance coming let's brush our
post-production and really as an indie
filmmaker your post-production time is
the one luxury you do have is time you
don't know is that money so take your
time with your films and don't worry
about festival deadlines they will come
and go and you know the good thing is
now 20 years after we started Slavens
there are more festivals out there I
mean
the year we started it was also the year
that within that year kind of radius
that the South by Southwest started by
Hampton started la Film Festival started
New York undergrad Chicago underground a
lot of other festivals started kind of
in that year and so now if you missed
the Sundance deadline it's not the end
of the world you know you can premiere
your film at South by or at Tribeca or
or in international festivals you know
or Toronto it's there's always more
festivals so don't rush your deadlines
oh no it sounds great
and I like what you say about how don't
let one festival program or sort of
determine how you should gear your film
because you may not get in but then
there's that idea that hard-headed
artist that doesn't want to change their
idea despite the same feedback that's
giving well yeah I mean that look that's
my advice in general for filmmakers if
you are getting a consistent feedback
and not necessarily from festival people
but from anyone your friends family crew
your producers partners whatever you
know if one person says something you
can ignore them but if three or four or
five or ten people are saying
consistently the same thing now they may
not have the right solution I think
that's the that's the trap people fall
in like Oh ten people are telling me
I've got to change this cut because the
joke isn't working or I've got to take
cut this character well they may all be
pointing to the same problem but their
solution may not be the right solution
so you have to kind of think a little
bit deeper like okay these people are
all telling me something I don't know
what it is but there's definitely
something that is affecting people in
the same way and so you need to kind of
think okay what is the root of the
problem because remember when you show a
film to anyone else they don't know what
other footage you have and what other
footage you don't have so they can't
really give you good advice on how to
recut even your own producers you know
or your you know it's like it's really
you and the editor or if you are the
editor you know you're the only one who
knows what else there is and what else
there isn't and what the other options
were and how you could have cut this or
how you could
so but people are saying well the pacing
is this or the whatever you know
whatever advice whatever thing they're
latching on to it is worth while
listening to the nice thing about
comedies by the way is of course you can
always just see our people laughing
aren't they laughing you need about ten
people in a room before you can figure
that out with dramas it's a little
trickier you can't always tell
you